Wow.
Well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Everything is bullshit.
Bullshit.
Purpose.
Purpose,
purpose.
Purpose.
Big Machine.
Perfect.
Everything mushy.
Mushy.
Names are fruits now.
Lips or perps now
nips or Forbes now flips.
Refurbs now.
Nibs or Forbes.
Now it's so good.
It's amazing.
Big.
Big,
big,
big.
When she purpose big.
Big,
big,
bushy pearls
was genius.
Once you show purples,
mushy.
Mushy.
Purple.
Why not?
That's part of the song for a minute and did that really well.
They are most super bowls.
They're all covered in um,
skin tags to hey Mike Morgan,
Freeman,
freckles.
That was,
if you haven't figured it out,
the song mushy.
Purples by MC fluid bond and DJ glass.
Gender from Nashville.
Where's your purples?
Big Hit.
Big.
Sweeping the nation last in the nation.
Personally,
I'm a big mushy purples.
Oh,
stop.
I think you were a fan of my,
of my,
uh,
my flap wagons before I had a kid.
I think you tolerate them now because they're the only set that you get to
touch.
I know.
I'm out there on the road.
I'm doing stuff.
I'm busy.
The only set I'm touching.
You think I'm sticking to one set of purples?
Yeah.
No,
I hope so.
No.
Hello,
whose boobs are you touching?
Road Dog.
Hello Dog Road B.
I'm to get out of here and now that you're all skinny on myself there on those
skinny jeans around this motherfucker,
he feel himself.
Ah,
um,
AH,
such a big episode we're going to get into.
Yeah.
Why don't we,
um,
why don't we get it going?
What do you see?
Parables.
You ready to get those purples going?
Yeah,
man.
Let's,
uh,
oh shit.
The fucking shuttle tater.
Did I send myself fuck,
fuck shit
off again.
I'll do it when I'm fucking doing the other thing.
Oh,
okay.
Um,
you are?
Yeah.
Here we go.
Okay,
let's start the show.
Ready gene.
Yeah.
Let's party.
Got Sex.
And when you open someone mode,
he used to make you shit in his mouth like that.
I've never had done that before.
And this isn't an experience for a man.
Then he asked him to shit in his mouth then.
So,
ah,
man,
Huh.
Don't bring in one mothering to this,
Christina.
Oh,
that was big
barbells.
These are a Pilipino ladies.
Yeah.
Um,
I don't know if they're a Pilipino or if they are all at the same kind of Latin
to me.
It didn't seem to like,
oh,
I heard Pilipino.
I thought,
wouldn't it be funny if they're talking about my dad?
Oh,
he's named me Sa,
but Jetski yeah.
Now they're talking about a really,
uh,
a famous guy.
Um,
no kidding.
Yeah.
His name.
I have it here in that cheat sheet somewhere.
Hold on.
This guy,
the Cathy,
is that McAfee?
It says that in the title.
Yeah,
the clip macafee shit.
What's he known for?
He was known for,
he's the,
uh,
the McAfee antivirus.
Right.
I thought so.
I've heard the name.
So if you,
um,
I'm sure you've seen if you've used the computer anytime in the last,
uh,
a PC,
I used to have this on my old computer before I had an apple like logo look like
McKesson.
Yeah.
It's familiar,
right?
Yeah.
He had a branded virus,
right.
Antivirus thing.
Hey mine.
Is My mic super hot?
Yeah.
Can you turn it down?
That's better.
Yeah,
there we go.
That's much better.
Yeah.
Everyone's seen the,
um,
the images.
Right.
And he'd
open his mouth and do it and they make a messy brown.
I'm the human beat day.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
So apparently he's a,
he's a,
yeah,
he's a scat guy.
He's that guy.
Yeah.
He likes,
he likes a puppy in his mouth.
I like the book
mouth.
Wow.
Through a hammock.
I didn't,
I missed that.
I was so maybe that,
that part.
I,
uh,
I got a head.
These poor women.
How,
how much in a hard way do you have to be for that to be your,
he did this in Belize actually.
I don't know.
I would shit,
I would shit in somebody's mouth.
That's not that big of a deal.
So nasty.
It's nasty,
but it's not that crazy.
For the first time I was a famous,
then I got used to say she loves it.
You do sit down this hallmark hallmark,
they have market as a whole,
a hallmark and after that he lays on the hammock.
Then he,
you know,
he would cut a little hole and he would sit there.
That's why he used it for,
cause he,
he wanted to have Scott sick fan and then I didn't agree with that.
Yeah.
Scott sex.
So let me get this straight.
How long do you think it took him to come up with the hammock system?
How many,
how much trial and error?
Oh,
there's a little bit of it for sure.
For he's like,
wait a minute.
You got to get a Hammock,
you got to cut a hole.
This big.
The hammock isn't,
isn't genius.
And a number of ways.
First of all,
who doesn't like it makes the,
the user comfortable.
He's like,
Oh,
you know,
so why is there the whole in the hammock then your,
your body does something on a hammock is the,
in that it's naturally designed to poop better because of the hanging interest.
Saburn your body weight is pulled down more.
Wow.
Right.
So that's exactly kind of the ideal way to shit your body weight.
Well,
let me think.
Hold on.
Let me think.
Maybe.
And I think too,
if the hammock is just low enough that your feet touch the ground and it pushes
your knees kind of up towards you mouth and God damn it.
And this is Belize.
So these are third world dumps.
These chicks are taking.
This is not,
uh,
you know,
you're saying after the steakhouse at Fleming.
Yeah.
You're not Swiss dumps,
right?
That's the distinction you're making.
That if it was down ice first world country,
right,
this would be a flavorful thing to do.
Less
bacteria.
What has got,
and when you,
when someone moves and he used to make you shit in his mouth like that,
she had a sense of humor about it.
She's not,
say Trump done that before.
And it was an experience for me and
he asked him to shit in his mouth.
So
yeah.
One of these girls are scarred regular intercourse.
Vaginal intercourse.
Not Easy Gig.
Not Up that easy.
It was the only thing I did
talk about an easy gig now that I think about it,
you know,
same with these guys who liked getting kicked in the nuts.
Uh,
these guys who like getting farted in the mouth,
shitting in the mouth,
super easy money.
Absolutely nothing.
His mouth right depends on one
book
and there's such nice girls there.
So like sweet little beggar who's really smiling.
She's like,
I think sheets every day and now someone wants to eat it.
Denies this experience.
He's Arabic spirit of space and experience.
Yeah,
I guess.
I mean if somebody wanted to hire you to do that,
I don't,
I don't know.
How much do you think she'd they get for that?
I Dunno,
he's in Belize.
I'm sure he was just like,
do you want a hundred bucks?
A hundred bucks?
Yeah.
I think that's too much for beliefs.
No,
I think the reason he would do that is that so it's undeniable cause it's 100
bucks is nothing to him.
So yeah,
he probably would be like,
you know,
don't worry about it.
Just keep coming.
Keep coming over here and shit over here.
He should have also said don't talk about it.
Yeah.
These chicks did a documentary on him.
Let's see.
That's such a,
so wait a minute.
So they poop in his mouth.
That can't be good for you.
Yeah.
How do you not get sick from that?
Good question.
You want to see what he looks like?
Absolutely.
Can I guess wait before you do it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Here's my guests.
Obviously a white guy.
You got that?
I'm going to go fifties I'm going to go reddish brown hair.
Kind of like the stapler.
Swingline stapler guy in office space.
Reddish Brown hair and disgusting facial hair.
Okay.
Okay,
go ahead.
Oh
Wow.
Well he's not out of shape.
I imagine him out of shape.
He's got problems than beliefs for sure.
This guy doesn't look like not the guy who wants to get his mouth shut and you
don't know.
He looks like the guy who likes to get his mouth fuck can,
hey man,
shit,
this guy takes the loaves loafs in his mouth and let's see you smile too.
He's like,
that's,
that's him.
When he meets you looking at you,
if you're a woman.
And he's like,
imagine that dump in his mouth.
I wonder what the fs,
I actually understand after our show,
I think our show helped me understand the fart fetish more.
We met people that were there and I started understand,
oh,
especially when they're like,
I like the idea of the pretty beautiful woman with the dirty smell and you're
like,
okay,
I get it.
There's a taboo.
They totally get it.
Shit in your mouth is such another level for me.
I mean,
it's,
well,
it's so disgusting.
It's not even discussing on a subjective level.
You know,
it's,
it's such a health hazard.
You know,
it's uh,
it's something that can make you so unbelievably sick.
It's so,
God damn,
I just don't understand what the fuck the,
the allure is.
Jeez,
look at this one.
It looks like,
see this was after he ate a bad shit.
This is hepatitis is not,
I have to take a bad shit.
This is,
I ate someone shit
here
for Dui and gun possession.
The thing is,
Ooh,
this guy's crazy.
If you're Gunna let some chicks shit in your mouth,
do it in the first world because listen to you like that makes a difference.
There's hepatitis.
Of course.
It doesn't make Brent worms.
Ringworm.
I don't know what I'm saying.
Absolutely.
You're so far off on this.
I'm just kidding.
I don't know.
Let's see.
Let's see what he's worth.
Oh my God.
He must be worth a lot that every 100 million.
That's when you go to Belize and get girls to shit in your mouth because life is
no longer exciting for you.
It looks like.
Uh,
what?
What else can you do with your life?
His board,
his believes compound where he lived before he snuck out of the country to avoid
talking to police about a murder boy was burned to the ground.
Oh Wow.
Wow.
This guy's scandalous.
Yeah,
so he's walking around.
These poor girls are probably just village road.
Hey,
come here.
Then we got some shit.
He drive through the village.
Who's got to take it down?
Maybe he goes to Starbucks there.
It says he lived with a Harem of young women and would doesn't some of which you
said were presented to him as 16 year old prostitute.
Yeah.
Not The coolest guy that we've talked to.
Beating them fiber.
Yeah.
You got shit yet.
I'm tech Shit.
So we should catch people up.
Obviously last week I was here and I was telling you that I hope I,
I would be having a still have a beard and I do because you are the weight loss
champ.
I am the weight loss champion of the entire world.
Congratulations.
Thank you very much.
That was a victory well deserved.
And it really,
both of you are winners at the end of the day,
right?
Uh,
we are,
we are both winners.
The bigger winner,
a better winter.
Um,
and uh,
La last week,
Monday,
it was tough episode to get through cause I was in the middle of that weight
cut.
I remember I was staring at water.
I was like,
ah,
brutal.
Weight cutting is brutal.
It's so hard for you to refrain from drinking water because you don't normally
drink that much anyways.
You know it's funny,
Jeff Tate said it best when it was my water consumption.
He goes,
you're not just winning the water,
drinking battles.
You're running up the score.
And I was like,
what a what an appropriate thing to say to offer.
Jeff takes some feature weeks,
but I'm not going to anymore.
I'm sure he's deeply offended.
Dumb Shit like that.
Yeah.
Do you think he wants to feature for you?
Maybe he does.
I don't think so.
Why not?
Probably because he's above that.
Yeah,
I know,
but I've got a better personality than you and I feel like he'd want to hang out
with me more.
This is the dumbest thing you've said yet,
and this one's going to hurt your feelings because you brought this up last
night.
I don't know why you brought it up,
but you were trying to talk about which of us has a better personality or weight
loss too.
I don't want to be a little that.
Yeah,
well,
I was talking about that last night.
I don't know how it came up,
but I thought to myself,
it's obvious that I have a better personality than you and it must be hard
being,
you know.
Um,
and I know I couldn't tell if you were joking or what was going on and I'm not
joking.
I'm serious.
I have such a better personality than you are early.
This one is so silly.
It's so silly.
I mean,
I,
I can take into account some of the jokes,
you know,
even though it's clearly night and day with this water stuff that I'm a Bayer
consumer,
when it comes to personality,
chances are much better than you.
Not even one person that knows the two of us.
First of all,
an example.
Anybody that no two of us is around you.
Like,
you know,
like,
oh,
like people,
people love me.
They know they don't love you.
Nobody loves the way people like me.
That's not true.
Much more than,
you know.
Nobody feels that way.
People tolerate you.
That's true.
People are okay with you being around.
I'm celebrating.
It's totally different.
I know,
I know you are more popular than me.
Uh,
you're definitely famous,
like,
you know what I mean?
You're famous or more famous.
That's not what I'm talking about in our private life.
It's me 10 to one.
First of all,
your family like me way more than they like it.
It's so obvious.
Your dad talks to me all the time.
He enjoys my company.
Your mother likes,
he likes those mushy purples.
It's only the only talking to you when we're in green rooms.
This is you.
Wait,
when are we in green?
In green rooms together.
If we happen to work a weekend together,
you'll be on your phone the whole time.
The last time that
that's okay.
First of all,
you're talking about a work.
It's a totally different thing.
But yeah,
if you'd go to all the,
any comedy club and you go like,
yeah,
but like,
who's your favorite?
I'm on their list for sure.
Who is your favorite comic or no?
Favorite person?
Person,
person.
Everybody likes me more.
No,
no one would have you on their list if you,
if you talk about like,
oh,
the valet,
the guy that you know,
the,
the host,
uh,
at the,
at the restaurant that greets you and you're,
and it's like,
Hey,
you met that couple that they would all be like,
that guy was great.
He was so much fun.
He brought,
he just brought a certain level.
He had such a dynamic personality and he was so fun just to have a,
he was charming.
He should ask our friends and then they would say like,
oh,
he brought that dud with him.
But uh,
but I guess,
you know,
I dunno,
he's,
maybe he's doing a favor.
I think we should ask the people in our lives,
you're going to get your feelings hurt.
Horribly.
Vote for who they like,
like who's got a,
and I'm not saying that they like more,
but who's got a better personality?
And I just,
I think in my heart that you really,
really think that my personality,
like I'm just more fun.
You're not more fun,
so much more,
much colder.
You're much older,
much.
I have two dogs that I lavish with.
Love that you're one of those models.
When those people was like,
I'm not good with people.
I like the animals and which is fine.
It's fine.
I think the animals appreciate it.
They need you.
Human beings feel like you're cold.
Absolutely.
Much,
much more kind of a downtrodden whether personality.
Definitely.
You said last night you're like,
you're,
you're more like solen.
Yes,
I am in I am,
but not all the time.
No,
but most of the time.
Yeah.
Like I would say that I have,
I'm definitely a dark sided.
I'm,
I'm more of the dark side.
The dark side.
Yeah.
I'm not,
I'm not like a,
you know,
Bimbo free.
Hey,
we're talking about like all the time.
Yeah.
And I know I'm definitely dark,
but I also,
I think that my personal,
I'm friendly,
I'm friendlier to people.
I'm just more dynamic than,
you know,
I'm more,
I already know what's going to happen.
By the way,
on these emails we're going to get bombarded with like,
it's going to be all chicks that go.
I just want to say I saw that episode and I love seeing that you're definitely
my favorite and they'll talk about how to love you,
but just know they're doing that the way someone does to like a kid who got left
out and I didn't get picked on the team.
So everybody's like,
oh we're playing ball and one kid standing on the sideline like,
oh wish I could play.
And then a lady comes over and puts her arm around him.
That's what's going to happen.
So they're going to get a bunch of shit to tell you that you're the fucking
winning person.
The personality champion.
I'm also the water champion.
You might be the weight loss champion,
but I'm the personality champ and the water,
it's been open for a long time.
You're just holds my fourth one of the fucking lie.
First of all,
the filtration system and our house isn't working.
Who demanded that we pull over and get water before you show me you didn't even
notice that shit cause you don't care.
I drink gallons of water a day.
What is wrong with you?
God,
it's not a battle anymore.
It's just in the past now,
man,
I'm the personality champ
as the personality champion because my personality is just more loving and kind
and giving.
I like to discuss your weight loss some more.
Everybody wants to know how are you feeling?
How would you do it?
Just like afterglow because you have so much good reason to,
a
glow from us.
You are right.
I do.
And um,
I also thought about that.
I would do at some point,
I think I'm going to do,
uh,
a an episode of your mom's house,
like an extra episode just dedicated to weight loss.
That's a great idea.
Just talk all about everything.
I'll give you the quick summary of Le just so people know all about the wage and
everything.
You know,
we touched on it.
I don't know if you watched Joe Rogan,
uh,
last week,
on Monday and Tuesday,
Bert Kreischer and I went in and spent two full days,
uh,
where we were.
We had a weight loss bet going.
Here's people because a few people have misinterpreted the bet just so they know
what the vet was.
Cause I've even seen some people go,
well technically,
no,
you don't know what the wager was.
The wager was this,
it was not a,
a percentage of body weight.
It was not who started way or an ended up where it was a straight up who weighs
less by the date.
That's it.
So if everybody's like,
well what if the BMI or what if the,
we had a hit,
he and I had a straight up who could lose more weight bet.
Okay.
That's first.
Secondly,
as far as the starting weights,
when the bet was sealed,
like it was on,
the handshake was made over the phone.
He claimed to be to 40 and then I said I was two 42.
And where are you lying?
I was between when you started.
When we started our bet.
Okay.
And when was this?
What month?
It was November,
early November.
Oh Wow.
See,
I started losing weight in August.
He,
uh,
and he,
he said he was two 40 when we started the vet a week afterwards.
He told me he was two 50.
Okay.
Meaning he's weighs more than what he claimed.
I,
when I said I was two 42 I was maybe two 44 so I was in the range.
He said it was two 50 when we did rogue and he goes,
I was two 56 so he added another six pounds.
But that's a bird ism because here's why he,
the two 56 is what he weighed after on Thanksgiving after he binge ate and
drank.
So it was an inflated number.
In other words,
he's giving himself too much credit for having lost.
Yup.
Yep.
Maybe he two 50 when he said he was two 40.
Here's the point.
We both lost a bunch of legit weight and then on the last couple days we did a
water cut,
which is like what wrestlers and fighters do to make waves so miserable because
we both,
because our side bet is this.
Well,
here's the other thing I hated the bet was made with Ari Arie Schaffer,
uh,
the comedian who,
his whole thing was,
he wanted us to get out of obesity on the BMI scale.
It's really funny,
by the way,
to just be overweight and not obese.
Yeah.
Now,
if you listen to the podcast where the,
where the bet was made,
there is height is brought into it and height has an effect on your BMI.
This is what people don't know.
This is where the discrepancy and all the bickering came afterwards.
So if you want to be out of obesity and simply overweight according to the BMI
scale and you're six one,
you are,
uh,
I think you have to wait to 27.
Okay.
So the whole thing was like get the two 27 burden.
I had a side bet of whoever got lower wins.
Not only that,
the bat,
but also the loser would have to shave their beard.
So that was our side bet.
So that's why we kept trying to go below that.
After the bet was initially made,
I got a call from,
from Ari Shaffir Arie Schaffer.
Yeah.
And we started to go over this bet and he goes,
well,
you know,
heightwise if there's a discrepancy between the two of you,
um,
you know,
then he might be able to know,
like,
we might be able to weigh more than you.
And I told him I'm not doing that.
Right.
So you guys discussed that earlier part,
then the game,
well don't know anything.
Right?
And so for people that go like,
well what do you mean?
I told him,
I go,
dude,
I'm doing a straight up weight loss challenge with Bert.
Like that's what I'm agreeing to.
And we had a conversation which he did agree to and I said,
just tell me what the goal weight is and e
which in Ari is two 27 okay.
Now in
going further in this thing,
we then waited on day one on day one of the way in Burt was two 21 and I was two
19 so we absolutely smashed the goal weight.
Great.
I was so nervous by the way.
I was watching on Joe Rogan's website.
Yeah.
Joe Rogan.
What does it.live five yeah.
And I was sitting in this room along with the dogs just like freaking out biting
my nails because Burt wait in first.
That's right now going when he got there,
let's say.
Yeah,
let's go.
Let's go through the moment.
When he got to that,
when he got so exciting,
he got to Rogan.
He goes first.
He goes,
yeah,
I'm running there from his house,
his house,
which was like crazy or two miles turn.
I took an Uber to the corner and then just jog.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but he ran out his house.
Funny how far?
I did not know that had a cop with him.
Oh,
areas
and I was like,
ah,
I got this.
Yeah.
I thought maybe Burt doesn't know to avoid fluid.
Yeah,
so I thought he was going to down a cup of water,
which I was so excited about.
On Day one I was watching him and he was chewing ice and spitting it out and
like chewing.
Some of it's sucking on it because he was dehydrated.
Anyways,
I go,
what do you think you wait?
He's like,
I think two 27 like he thought he was at the goal weight and how he was like,
I think I'm shaving my beard.
I go,
okay.
And I looked at him and I knew,
you know,
it looked like he was thinner than he had been.
Yeah,
he's definitely,
he looks much better.
Yeah,
he looks,
Oh,
the other part I have to backtrack before I get to this,
after that,
Ari Shaffer a call about the,
uh,
the goal weight thing,
I immediately called Bert,
which he would attest to and said,
hey,
I just talked to,
to show fear and he's talking about like half inch here and how the boy and Burt
was like,
no,
it's a straight up weight loss shout.
So that's just for the people who go,
well,
technically if you're hide is this and the BMI,
we agreed to terms,
right?
Yes.
Now when we're waiting,
I really do think Bert must be like two 25.
So wait,
hold on,
hold on.
But let's back it up a little bit more because I,
can we be frank here about what you did the night before that way in.
Can we tell the audience really what went down?
Yeah,
sure.
Lunacy that went down in this house because it was fucking,
I,
I've known you for 12 plus years now.
Yeah.
I have never seen you this laser focus,
this disciplined and this determined to win.
Yeah,
no,
I've seen you focus like I'm,
don't get me wrong,
you're very disciplined.
Even keeled,
dude.
But this was,
I was scared a little by day.
The second day of land,
I was getting a little nervous that something was going to go wrong and then
we'd have to go to the hospital or you'd be sick.
So the neighbor tell,
tell people what you did before the first way.
Okay.
Again,
this is so fucking crazy.
We legit,
we're down.
Both of us were down below the two 27.
Right.
So you knew that you,
you'd already won the general facts.
Yeah.
Getting lower.
So I talked to a,
I'm a fighter,
uh,
Jake Smith,
this guy,
to be clear,
you don't,
you'd already won the bet is what you're saying.
Well,
I knew that.
I knew that I was,
you may low the,
made the weight and I'm saying that came from months of eating Kido and doing a
lot of,
you did it.
You did it the right way.
Yeah.
Now what you work I with was having your beard shaved.
And also just the,
when you just want to win,
you want it to,
to yeah.
To be,
yeah.
Bert.
Yeah.
Just wanted to win.
So,
uh,
my buddy,
this guy hit me up,
we were talking and he tells me about the week of,
so actually my,
my real cuts started bananas cuts started in Orlando because he told me that,
I'll just tell you what he said.
He said the weight the week before you want to start nothing but distilled
water.
Great.
This is to ensure the body gets into flushing mode.
All right?
Uh,
drinking lots of water early on the body will downregulate Aldosterone,
a hormone that acts to conserve sodium and secrete potassium.
And when you suddenly reduced the amount of,
you drink in the middle of the week,
your body will still be in fleshing mode.
You piss a lot.
So some fighters like to reduce the water after Tuesday to three quarters of
Wednesday,
half gallon.
Like I said,
whatever.
He goes,
I personally don't do that.
It's up to you.
Here's how he does it.
Sunday,
two gallons.
Monday,
one gallon,
Tuesday one gallon,
Wednesday one gallon,
Thursday one gallon,
and then you stopped drinking exactly 24 hours before you weigh in Friday.
No water until after you weigh in.
So all I did was water wise,
I did a modified version of what he told me to do.
What was the modification?
I did two gallons on Thursday,
one gallon Friday,
one gallon Saturday,
half a gallon Sunday.
And the reason I did that was that I knew that I had two days of weigh ins,
so I knew that I would want to,
it was okay to way to,
to drink more on Sunday before Monday,
way in,
and then drink far less Monday for a Tuesday because we had a two day Wayne.
Oh,
it was crazy.
So the two day,
Wayne,
I know there was more dramatic,
brutal.
So what I did was I did all those things with water.
I mean,
I,
I was still eating a very kito diet,
which was like high fat,
moderate protein,
just cleans,
yeah.
In clean.
Um,
and then he also gave me a tip that this,
uh,
Abilene is like this,
this,
I know that's a makeup remover.
I think thing,
I don't know.
But anyways,
fighters use it.
You put it all over the body opens up your pores and then you sweat more in a
sweaty situation.
So what I would do is,
um,
at night,
wait a minute,
what you would do or what I would help you do?
Well,
I mean we can we be real here.
It was a,
it was a mommy mommy effort.
Yeah.
You're going to take a hot bath,
right?
So we've met who drew a hot bath.
Okay.
And then,
uh,
rub that all over.
I rubbed that all over your body.
That's right.
And as a dutiful wife,
I shaved your back thoroughly.
It took about half hour.
Did Not Take it.
Yes it did.
No,
I shaved.
You're back down.
Nice and Dolphin smooth.
And then that shit on your body.
Are you getting the hot water?
You,
you getting the hot bath?
Uh,
sweat.
Oh,
and we turn the heat on.
He ends.
That's right.
Heat from the hot water.
Here's another thing I learned and not even from him,
I was just reading about this.
A lot of people get to that sweating and then you shower.
Obviously they go home and take a shower.
Now what I read was that some people,
if you're in a sweating mode and you jumped in the shower,
your body reabsorbs water because your pores are open.
So what you're supposed to do,
his towel off between sweats keep toweling off,
not shower until after Wayne.
So I did that too.
Yes,
she did.
And I was sitting in the bathroom with you keeping you company.
Yeah,
and I had to walk out because it was too hot in there and I was going to pass
out.
So I did that at night and then in the morning I would go to Burke Williams,
the spa rubbed the Abilene all over again and then do the steam room.
I know.
And then that would do a is insanity.
10 minutes in five minutes,
not only the bath tub.
Here we have a hot tub and then I went to the hot sun.
You were upset because the hot tub when it go to 104 had it reset and it,
and it works now.
Yeah.
He called the guy to come and make the hot tub hotter so that you could sweat
more.
Now at which point I was getting nervous because you're basically dehydrating
yourself,
which you're used to because you don't drink a lot of water in the first place,
but you are professionally dehydrating yourself and you're not,
you're not a professional boxer.
Like you just had this email from this dude and you're like,
I'm going to drink distilled water and,
and poison myself here.
So and,
and you did it like a week before.
So I'm Kim,
I'm like,
this got your liver is going to shut down.
I don't know what's going to happen.
I don't like it at all.
Well this is also,
oh shit.
The uh,
so day one was,
you know,
we weighed in,
um,
two 19.
Okay,
so you two 19 and March two 21.
No,
hold on.
But you go to Pittsburgh bark volumes.
Yeah.
And you sweat before the weigh in.
Right now.
You don't know how,
do you know how much you've lost?
Not really that good morning or no,
I don't know.
I remember
that I left the house.
Uh,
well I don't remember this Monday morning I wake up and I think,
um,
I'm like two 21 to 21 is my before I'm right.
So,
so I'm like,
okay,
I eat,
I'd eat a little something.
Just yeah,
get you through the day.
Well,
get to weigh in.
And I actually,
I think I ate too much and I then eat that much.
But I did have a whole egg.
Right.
And I think something mixed in with it just because,
I mean,
I was hungry.
Crazy.
Yeah.
And then I'm like,
ah,
I think I ate too much,
but I'm like,
okay,
uh,
I go sweat anyways when I weigh in.
I'm two 19,
so,
which means that I'm two pounds less than when I woke up.
It's not that dramatic,
you know?
Then the next,
then when we get home from Wayne's,
we do the podcast last week and now I'm like really trying to cut water until
the next morning.
Right.
So I have very,
very little between leaving Joe's getting here and the next misery.
And I agree.
I do a two and a half Mile Trek,
uh,
on the elliptical,
which I was sweating a good bit from then about sanity,
about an hour and a half after that,
I do the hot bath again.
The again towel off,
no water,
and then the next morning,
wait,
wait.
Again,
you're bright.
You know,
you're,
the story is all from your perspective,
which I understand the other perspective is you're sitting at the dinner table,
little jeans,
maybe jeans and I were trying to like have a dinner and you're just suffering.
Like I can see it in your eyes.
Your eyes are sunken in.
You got these dark circles,
you're just fucking miserable.
You can't even drink water.
And at which point you're like,
I just,
I got to go upstairs.
I got to go.
I wanted to distract myself.
Miserable.
Yeah.
I want it to distract myself.
It was horrible.
Part of it would be like,
I would get so tired that sometimes I could fall.
All you wanted to do with false of course.
And then I would also try to just distract.
So I would read an article and then realized I was losing myself in the,
which was good.
Yeah.
So that time,
and then the hardest part was the,
um,
the night before and the morning I was the hardest part.
But so the night before you fall asleep,
you're like,
thank God we get up at six 30.
I know we have an 1130 way in.
So the first thing I say to you is five hours.
I got five hours on.
Horrible.
And then we're downstairs,
we're going to breakfast with a little ear man.
And then I looked at seven 30.
I'm like,
I got four hours at a time.
It's eight 30.
I was like,
I know I need to get ready to get going.
So I do remember the album and again,
everywhere.
It was horrible this time.
I know also that I didn't push myself as much as I could have in that steam
room.
So I know to do it more like to push it harder the second day.
So I know to like stay in a little longer and I know to do it for longer.
So I do that.
The second day I did it for longer.
Now one thing I noticed that wasn't in your regimen was a good old fashioned,
um,
taking a shit like you didn't know the cleanse.
Yeah.
Cause I feel like,
and I gave you the diet or tea and I went to get and you didn't shit.
And I felt like you could lose another five or 10 pounds of just shit.
I think it was picking a lane.
I was picking a lane.
You picked water over dump.
I picked water.
Oh,
I can't,
can't you do both?
Don't,
I mean,
do you boxers shit in addition to sweat?
Yeah,
I guess.
I guess so.
Yeah.
I just,
I,
the thing was I was consuming so little food right the last 72 hours that I
don't think that there was,
you say that.
Yeah.
But you'd be surprised because I accidentally drank some dieters t in college
and I wasn't eating a lot to have one.
I did it.
You need more.
I told you you got to double bag.
And I remember when you think there's no brown in you,
there's all,
there's always a lot of brown in you.
There's always a lot of brown in you.
I know.
I'll never be doing that again.
It was terrible.
Horrible.
Terrible to watch the next,
oh,
I hate it.
I went in again,
I was two 16.
Yeah.
Which means I lost an additional three pounds.
Crazy.
Just from sweating.
Yeah.
And then this crazy,
or it was two 20 so he lost one pound.
So it was,
it was,
you know,
it was over.
I started to drink fluid there.
Right.
And so the first thing we did was drink these,
uh,
coke CO2,
I forget.
It's called,
um,
coconut water,
right?
Yeah.
They're big man.
They're like 27 ounces or something.
So we're so dehydrated,
the down,
no problem.
Then he has 16.9 ounce bottles of water,
which is like,
you know,
like uh,
how many of those,
it's like this is 50.7.
Okay,
well I drink six to 16.9 ounce bottles of six of you feel your body goes.
No,
it felt I was so dehydrated that it felt completely normal.
Then I had a second of the coconut,
the big 20 ounce bottles of thing and somebody texted me and I don't even know
if it's correct,
but let me see.
Uh,
how many ounces are in a gallon?
Um,
as it might be.
It's 100 2,828 gallons.
128 ounces are in a gallon.
So cause somebody pointed this out to me.
Yeah.
I he's like,
you just casually drank a gallon of fluid.
That's how dehydrated I was.
Oh,
the whole thing is that I was,
I drank that amount and didn't go pee.
That's crazy.
You're poor body.
Do that again.
I never want to do that again.
Horrible.
We both said that to each other though.
Like I would never ever do that.
Then I got to shave Burt's beard and he laughed and he gave him a Puerto Rican.
I tried to,
yeah,
that was the best part.
If you look it up on youtube,
it's really,
it's uh,
we laugh,
we laughed so hard looking at each other through it.
Um,
but it just type in Thompson gross shaves,
Burns beard.
And it's really fun man.
So anyways,
um,
I'm going to do a special weight loss,
a podcast at some point here and I'll put it up.
It'll just be an extra episode.
And um,
I'll get into detail about the whole,
the whole journey.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'm in workout gear right now because I'm going to go from the podcast to go
work out good for you jeans.
Um,
okay.
So,
and many thanks to Joe and then the bet,
the bet afterwards.
So here's what happened.
The discrepancy became about the BMI because we were supposed to get out of
obesity and into overweight.
So,
so our,
he's like,
yeah,
but I want to know your height now because so now he's going back to the
original and I go,
yeah,
but you agreed to the two 27 goal weight.
He's like,
he has,
he has like Amnesia,
right?
So now he's like,
no,
no.
I want to know your height.
So we measure my height without shoes obviously.
Um,
and I'm just under six feet.
So technically I'm five 11 and like eight five 11.85 so,
but I'm closer to six feet then I am the five 11 most of the online BMI things
where like you had to pick an inch,
you know,
like a,
a good round number.
So if you did five 11
I'm not in the correct whatever BMI for it.
If you had six feet,
you're giving me too much credit and I go,
yeah,
but you got,
so anyway,
somebody found one that had five 11.5 which I'm taller than.
Turns out I was
okay
at the correct way to win,
but only on day two,
not on day one.
Okay.
So then Ari
said that he wasn't going to pay.
Um,
he got bombarded with people calling them out.
Uh,
Joe then was like saying that he wanted to,
uh,
you know,
take like send us,
some ways going to assume Ari's dead.
He said,
and then,
but then to be fair,
gentlemanly,
to be,
to be fair to Ari a couple days later,
I don't know if it's because he got so much hatred or he just had a a moment.
He wrote this really sweet email to Bertrand and I about like how proud he was
of us and how we're going to be alive now longer and,
and how he's like,
whatever it costs are now.
He said he's going to do it.
He's going to do it.
I approved juice.
Yeah.
So he should,
yeah.
You guys worked very hard and 10 to Welch on that.
That would have been really shitty.
Well,
the truth is that,
you know,
I think we both did it outside of the,
the weight that the stakes,
but you know what I mean?
Like that was just the icing on the cake,
right.
That there was some payoff.
We didn't do it because we wanted to go to a fucking game.
We did it because we wanted to do it right.
We wanted to get help.
But that's what I'm saying,
that it's especially shitty for someone.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Who,
if he didn't do it,
you know,
take knowledge,
the amount of work and yeah,
that you guys put in because that's a ton of work
to be clear.
The three of us,
we're all all of means to deal with the repercussions if we didn't do it.
So it's not like talking to like,
it's not about what I'm saying,
it's not about money.
It's more about the acknowledgement and the gesture of hey,
you did it,
you did it.
Good job,
good job.
But only you only say that once a day.
You don't want too many good jobs.
Yeah.
I just think that Jews are great.
So,
so there you go.
Um,
it's over.
I'm back to being normal and by normal I just mean,
and then so when you were done with the bet the next day night,
no,
it was later that day.
Cause you guys ordered pizza and in Joe's studio,
and I had a piece and not even a half,
but that wasn't your jam cause you're a jam is sweets and you haven't had
pastries in like months.
So the very first thing we did,
we
got in the car and we found you a waffle place.
Yeah,
we got you Chuckii croissant.
But we didn't get to go to the waffle place I wanted to go to and now it's
closed already.
I know.
So we'll have to do a waffle date again.
But we did go and um,
we had,
uh,
some sweets and uh,
you know,
I gotta tell you though,
the,
the fantasy of them was better than the re then actually.
Yeah.
It kind of is because here's the thing,
when you have a little craving,
yeah.
I've found that just taking three bites is enough cause like,
oh,
I enjoyed that.
And if you go any for any further,
yeah,
now you're just punishing yourself.
You're,
you're kind of overdoing it and then you're not going to feel good.
Yeah.
And I didn't go cray.
I people were like,
you don't understand what's going to happen right now.
I was like,
dude,
and that's kind of not eating that much,
you know?
Yeah.
I think the Instagram photos you posted,
people think it was like a real hardcore binge.
I'm like,
I had a cookie,
a bite of the other thing,
and then the
and magic around,
uh,
three quarters of a chocolate croissant.
I didn't have three quarters of a chocolate croissant.
What did you have?
One quarter of a chocolatier as well then.
There you go.
Yeah,
it wasn't a lot.
That's my point guys.
It's the media.
Yeah.
I know the mainstream media was like totally distorting,
distorting what's happening to you.
And I haven't been emailing any of these people,
you know,
showing your Peter what?
Huh?
Okay.
Mimi,
Mimi.
But congratulations.
I'm very proud of you.
And last week was very happy week in this house when you one yeah,
it was great.
Everybody was pulling for you and it was very exciting.
And then day two of the weigh ins,
I remember I was sitting in my car and I was watching on my phone.
Yeah.
And I had to pull the car over and like scream you all.
I'd really,
I was so nervous for you cause I didn't know what Burt was going to do.
Right.
I mean I thought maybe burn had figured out cause there's a minute where Joe was
telling Bert that he should be sweating it out and I saw your luck cause I know
you so well.
They'll look on your face of like no,
no,
no.
She didn't say anything to him and I thought Oh my God,
if Burt goes home today and goes to sweat it out,
he could take Tom because he had to win.
He had,
he just had to overtake you by two and a half pounds.
That was the bet.
And he could have done that if he took a shit or sweat now.
But he couldn't have done it because I was,
I mean he could have been competitive,
more competitive,
but he,
I was already ahead of him so I was right.
You know,
he,
he was starting at a disadvantage,
know for him to make up and then beat me.
My,
he would have had to to drop,
you know,
I mean it's possible.
Are so far ahead with the sweating.
Well I wasn't that far ahead or two and a half pounds.
Two pounds.
That's why I was dramatic with it though.
Right.
Cause you didn't know what he was going to do that day.
That's right.
Thankfully not much.
He actually just,
he says he ran eight miles.
Um,
I found out that he run walks,
let's not give them to wait a minute.
So all those times he was showing the treadmill and he's like,
I did 22 miles.
How did he do that?
Did he just let it run the treadmill for like two hours and then he covered?
But what he would do is he would post it like I just covered miles.
He goes,
I would get up in the morning and he's still would deserve credit for the work,
but he would get up,
go in the,
in the,
um,
his man cave.
Yeah.
Get on the treadmill,
do three miles,
hit pause.
Oh,
for the day it's paused.
He would go about his day,
maybe go to a meeting,
whatever.
Take the girls somewhere,
come home five miles.
Hilarious.
Hit pause.
So now it's logged eight miles.
Sure,
sure,
sure.
Then he might walk,
he said like three or four miles.
Yeah.
Keep it going.
So he just kept it going at the talent.
Just kept a tally going,
which is,
I love it.
He fooled you on the day of,
he's like,
I jogged here.
No,
no.
I remember the day before he goes,
I'm a job there in the morning.
And I was like,
no.
Hilarious.
Yeah,
I did check and then I go,
where are you shyster cause he was late and he goes,
I'm on like,
you know,
on the street.
And I go,
you're,
you jogged here from real.
He's like,
yeah.
And then as I walk out with Jamie and we look and he's like,
like waving at his track suit on and uh,
and then Jamie's like,
he took it number and I go,
did you just take an Uber?
He's like,
yeah,
but dropped me off around there.
So he jog like the last hundred yards.
It's funny.
Yeah.
Oh,
alright.
Yeah,
it looks much better.
Much better than he does.
I mean,
I was just looking at a photo of him that was posted a while ago and he does
look like half the guy now,
Pam.
And it doesn't look bad without the beard shaved.
You know,
I do want to talk to Leanne about this and get her perspective.
She's mad at us are thankful I can't,
I don't know.
Yeah.
Last time we had them over for dinner and I,
I pulled her aside and I was legally and please tell me honestly,
is all this fat shaming bothering?
Yeah.
Bird is this bothering you?
Is this ruining your life?
And she and her wonderful Leanne way was like,
well you know Burt's going to do at Burt wants to do.
Yeah.
And I was like,
oh,
okay.
I guess that's not a no.
Yeah.
That,
so that means keep shaming him.
It's also a very uh,
Leanne answer.
Yeah.
Well it's true cause yeah.
Is going to do at bird's to,
do you remember the UV Micah?
Yes.
Most exciting man on the Internet.
Yeah.
He might have the capsules for me,
the already 20 and the [inaudible] as you can see,
they're quite different.
So we are already three 20 uses the same capsule design is in the Ari 27 and d
each had very well the face sports you already 20s or external and gallery three
corners are integrated into the capsules.
Sure.
The Ori 20 uses of standard gas 20
magnet to create even the title.
How are you three two,
one versus already joining?
Yeah,
VRE 20 sensitivity is 1.5 millivolts per.
So there's a competition now to see if anything could be more boring.
Maybe your personality and there's a submission for it.
Even hear that baby.
It's you can't,
you have to understand like you're going to get your feelings hurt so badly.
This I actually feel bad actually what I might have to like wink at a few people
and be like,
Hey,
she's not fun.
No one thinks you're more fun.
Um,
so here is the competition has,
oh for the most boring club,
more boring.
Here at Rockwell automations world headquarters,
we search has been proceeding to develop a line of automation products that
establishes a new standards for quality,
logical leadership and operating article already with customer success.
As our primary focus work has been proceeding on the crudely conceived idea of
an instrument that would not only provide in books.
Correct,
we're using unilateral phase detractors,
but would also be capable of automatically synchronizing cardinal grand meters,
Rockwell automations,
retro and calculator.
Basically,
the only new principal involved is that instead of power being generated by the
relative motion of conductors and fluxes,
I don't even know what he's talking about of it.
It's produced by the Modell interaction or reluctance and capacitive director is
he making these words up?
Sounds are made up and [inaudible] had a base plate of prefabricated amulet
surmount the casing in such a way that the two spring bearings ran a direct line
with the standard metric fam.
The lineup consistent simply of six copy Marzel veins.
It's fantastic.
All fit into the but patient lunar Wayne Chap,
that side fumbling,
it was effectively prevented who understand this video.
The main winding was of the normal Lotus,
so deltoid type placed in Penn Intermix,
Semi Bolo in slots of the stator Jesus.
Every seventh conductor being connected by a nonreversible tremie pipe to the
differential girdle spring on the,
there's like a Simpsons character.
Blue Band is blue band messing with me.
Do you think this guy is a host and he just got hired for this industrial
hundred percent he has a,
he's like,
he had to learn kind of what this crap was.
Unless,
is this just a bit,
I don't,
I don't think so.
Moreover,
whenever a fluorescent score motion is required,
it may also be employed in conjunction with a drawn reciprocation.
Dingo alarm.
Can we do on the soil?
Do you plan oration?
No.
The Rachio and calculator has no race.
No goddammit real words.
The diploma rater and the,
please tell me that the FARC urinated.
I hadn't seen that.
I just saw like the opening five seconds and I was like,
oh,
this is boring.
I didn't actually,
I hear his deformity in the flapper neighbors there and totally fake [inaudible]
by the [inaudible].
Moran is,
yeah.
Do you want to see a dad boner nonsense?
Yeah.
It's like it's a guy jerking off.
Okay.
Now this is a,
uh,
a super,
Super Dad Boehner who he doesn't get quite as excited as our glass of,
yeah,
our glasses,
color moose.
Super ultimate bad
just,
but this is pretty great.
Did they breach feeding?
He's on a boat.
No.
Pretty awesome.
It's pretty awesome now.
Wow.
Came up.
He just saw a fucking,
is it a pod of whales?
Don't know where it is.
I know.
Fucking
shit myself.
That was cool as fuck though.
It's a good,
good,
good moment,
right?
Yeah.
Let's go whale watching.
I think that'd be fun.
Yeah.
I want to do
okay.
Oh Lord.
Yeah.
Right.
It's really,
oh my God.
Now Evie,
my guy.
So look the,
it's obvious.
The,
the thing that's been taken over the world by storm has been,
Hi Mommy,
thanks genes and last weekend of the suck site.
And that is how we ordered when whenever we have a drive through a experience.
Yes.
We say hi Mommy.
And we say thanks jeans.
Yes.
And it has you added glass into it than other people that it is taken on.
It's exploded.
We had two blue and had to send selects because we had over 50 some submissive
missions.
People doing this and it would just be an entire show.
But sweeping the nation in the world.
There are some really,
and I have to tell you,
if you haven't done it yet,
do it because you feel,
yeah.
Even if you don't fill it,
it's such a,
it's a felony,
but it feels like such a sense of accomplishment.
You feel so fun.
It's so fun to like,
you got one in on.
Yeah.
It's harmless.
Hurting someone's feelings.
Yeah,
it's good fun.
So here is a,
here's one that I saw.
That is absolutely,
I think this is a master for one.
Hold on,
let me pull this up.
These are these good.
They'd be,
they've gotten better and better every week.
Let's see where this happened.
Hello jeans.
Sorry about that.
That's okay.
Mommy.
I can I just get a number six and number three?
Yeah,
but with the ketchup instead of,
yeah,
that would be amazing.
And can I check off whether that could be my Lord?
You know what,
I'm going to go full Burke Chrysler and could I just get it?
I'll just take a medium though.
We're different.
Burger F a R.
Yeah.
No,
no.
The meeting.
Oh,
medium.
Yes.
Jeans.
I have a drink.
Uh,
it's a postal.
It's a cool stuff.
Slips the pizza.
Probably a Dr Pepper.
Yeah,
that's a good one to take off the socks again.
I just can't you gotcha.
Jeans?
Yeah.
All right.
So did that what you,
that Guy Joe,
you got them on me.
All right.
Would that be all for you today?
Now that we had articles in the eight 81 at the window.
Thank you.
Wow.
He got in so many.
That's Cody.
Cody nailed it,
bro.
Yeah,
he got,
that was so good.
Mommy jeans.
I don't want to be,
I'm going to go full burnt Chrysler.
He went and then we were talking over,
he had a really good one.
What?
Which one?
Shit,
we were talking,
he had a really good one.
Really.
Then all the medium.
Yes.
Jeans.
Uh,
I want some cool stuff.
Slick stuff heats up probably.
Yeah.
And the way he runs through it fast.
Cool.
Status like seventies stuff.
Yeah,
that was great.
That's uh,
that's ultimate dad.
Uh,
Garth Brooks.
Oh,
so good.
Yeah.
Can I get a venti cold brew?
No.
Uh,
no.
light,
half and half.
Easy ice.
No water and a pump.
And a pump of vanilla.
Okay.
Can I also get a double pipe classic.
A double pipe classic.
If you don't have them,
that's fine.
They're really rare.
It's just nevermind.
It's okay.
That'll do it.
Damn.
What is that?
That's all right.
Thanks Jane.
How about
master?
What is,
they're very rare.
That was Daniel.
Wow.
Good job,
Dan,
for those?
Uh,
yeah.
One Sec.
I'm just glassing let me look for a second.
All right,
mommy.
I'm ready.
I get a medium water,
please.
Yes.
Actually,
actually,
uh,
um,
can I get a medium coke instead?
I'm trying not to fluid bomb with Jesse kinds of folk.
Um,
Maria,
do you want to meet him copper color,
correct?
Yes.
And then what's that Burger up in the corner?
The reason I like in the corner there who's get a cheeseburger
and does that come with mustard?
If those mustard on it,
you just wipe it off.
Just wipe down or you don't want mustard?
No,
no thanks.
And I think that will be it.
Yep,
that's it.
Thank you.
Alright,
thanks jeans.
Unreal.
The game has been elevated to a whole new life.
Surpassing anything we've ever done.
Oh sure.
That was Seth said you guys have killed it.
This is amazing.
Yeah.
So references in there.
I'm going to fluid bonded with Jesse.
I haven't got into the flow.
The vocal fry is get on her too.
Oh yeah.
I haven't got into if the bond with jazzy and then the ups speak at the end too.
I'm going to fluid bond with Jesse.
Jesse,
is that a question?
Generally they get Patricia McConnell kind of happiness.
I'll once I get mommy,
I'm just glassing for a second your time.
You guys have the new chicken McGriddle yes we did.
Can I get one of those and a small sprite please.
Do you want to make it a meal?
Um,
no thanks.
I don't want to be finding like Burt.
Uh,
yeah.
And uh,
that'll be oskies.
Okay,
so the smallest frame roll with it.
Yeah.
That's all going to be two 92 of the first one now.
Okay.
Thanks jeans.
Hi Mommy.
Can I get a large fry?
Make double with no ketchup.
Dumb.
I'll make chicken and a large elephant.
Classic
Khaki Color Classic.
Uh,
no,
that's it.
That's true.
Yup.
That's it.
To class.
I was Danny,
we have international order here.
Hi Mommy.
Can I get a chicken fries?
Chicken and a sorry.
And an ice cream cone.
Yup.
And a,
a large coke.
Zeros all paste.
Yeah,
that's a lot.
You think?
Thanks for coming.
Hi Mommy.
Can I get up?
Bakes,
egg and cheese on a sub came Bagel.
We get do this last week,
right?
I know what kind of Bagel multisoft came.
Bago Yep.
Can I also get a large coffee,
milk and sugar cane.
Okay.
And just got some,
do you guys still offer the turbo shot?
Yeah.
Can I get a turbo double pipe?
Classic shot.
Turbo.
See a coffee?
Yeah.
Yep.
That's it.
Thanks for about the past round.
Nope,
that's it.
Thanks jeans.
It's so funny,
man.
Nobody asks.
Nobody goes,
what's it?
What's the title?
You got it.
Hi me,
one second.
I'm just,
I'm just glancing.
Yes.
Can I get a McFlurry please?
Okay.
Yeah.
That's everything.
Thank you.
Have a good evening.
Thanks,
Jason.
Yes,
nationals.
Oh,
they're my favorite,
so yeah,
they've caught Jesus two.
What's a McDouble I make devil.
Yeah.
I'm sure it's double.
Double,
but no,
that's in and out,
right?
Like that was probably about double patty.
Right?
Like anything,
like a quarter pounder with cheese.
They have the metric system,
but didn't know.
You fucking know there was an American order.
Oh,
he didn't work?
I don't know.
Fucking,
And then chicken fries.
That was an Australia.
Yeah.
I don't know what that is either.
That sounds good.
Chicken fries.
Yeah.
I think it's like chicken fingers maybe.
Maybe that's what they call them there.
Yeah.
Guys,
what are chicken fries?
Let us know.
Okay.
Wow.
That was,
that was the highlight of my week doing a lay under the hammock.
I got to take it.
Yeah.
Uh,
under the hammock.
Oh God,
how much,
and someone will
ask me to shifting is it?
And I heard the Fart Mike.
Huh?
Did it register?
No,
you're kidding.
I mean,
I'm sure they heard it,
but it didn't register.
Oh,
so upsetting.
Yeah.
You did all that work and then no one's here to acknowledge these chairs,
like you've said before,
they're not conducive to farting.
Yeah.
You got to really lean over.
You got to practically lane,
you're in your shit hammock.
True.
Tom,
what do you think was the process leading up to that?
Because that's not where I would go first.
Oh,
it took a little bit of work.
It was like,
I don't know.
How do you coach someone into that?
Yeah.
You don't just say,
you gotta take a shit.
It's like,
would you do something?
You know what I mean?
Like what's the,
what do you think his first time doing it was like,
well,
he's like,
can you just squat over my face?
And the girls are like,
my thighs are burning.
Oh,
right.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I think he was just like,
yeah,
just squat.
And then he was like,
hold on to this while you squat,
like gave him a row.
He starts with a rep and they're like,
my thighs still burn.
Then it was like a box with a hole in it.
Like a bucket maybe.
Yeah,
I would have done that.
But then how does he sit under a buck?
And he realized that he's in Belize in those hammocks everywhere and people are
laying around and he was like,
dude of Hammock.
Is that right?
Perfect.
Shitting instrument.
It's kind of ingenious.
What do you think of it this way?
Yeah.
Um,
well this is our,
uh,
our show role.
What,
what I have a special announcement,
guys will announcement.
So June 16th and 17th,
I met the man friend disco and then man,
friend disco fluid bonding with Jesse at the punchline comedy club.
And I'm doing something special.
I'm doing a presale for our fans.
Presale,
presale,
presale.
That's a big announcement.
It's a big announcement.
Miss
that.
Yeah.
So Wednesday,
that's the day this episode drops between 10:00 AM and 10:00 PM.
You can go to the punchline comedy club Com website,
get your tickets.
Uh,
use the code genes.
J E a n a s jeans,
jeans,
jeans.
For one day,
only 10:00 AM to 10:00 PM Wednesday.
Get your tickets in advance.
You get,
you know,
better seating and just to make sure that you get the tickets that you would
want.
A smaller venue.
It's a smaller venue and I think we're going to sell a lot.
So yeah,
go there.
Also,
other dates coming up.
February 12th we only have a few tickets left for your mom's house.
Live at the Irvine Improv.
So if you want to car right,
you better get them because they're gone.
They're almost gone.
Yeah.
April 13th through 15th.
I met Brad at the Improv.
May 4th and fifth start next Arizona at standup live.
May 19th and 20th New York.
Shitty at Gotham comedy club.
You go Jude Dork titties.
Go to thousand ranch.com for tickets.
I'm in Oxnard at levity live.
Oxnard's Cox hard and uh,
are all mature.
I've heard it's a really great club.
I'm there this weekend,
Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday.
If you're in Ventura County,
I'll be there.
Um,
my tour is a,
it's really taken off.
Thank you to everybody that got tickets in advance.
I know that,
um,
a bunch of places are already sold out.
I believe New Orleans,
Atlanta,
I'm going to be in a clear Farder,
Florida,
Tallahassee.
Um,
I think there's still some tickets left for Tallahassee,
but the rest are going to be gone,
man.
Um,
Minneapolis,
there's only a couple of tickets left ass three shows there.
And apple sets.
Mini apple tips.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
sorry.
Minneapolis.
And then,
uh,
Chicago,
the shows are sold out.
We added a third show at the Vic theater,
so that's going to be the next day.
The 19th of March I think is the date that's on sale now.
It just got added Boston,
the two first show sold out.
So there's a third show on sale there at the Wilbur.
Um,
they're all at Thompson or a dotcom slash or genes.
Also,
I forgot,
I just added two local shows in La.
If you're in La,
come see me on February 17th at the Hollywood improv.
And then the 18th of February I met flip hairs.
Flappers comedy club.
8:00 PM shows on both of those 2000 ranch.com.
Yeah.
Two 17 and two 18.
Are you leaving town though when that week,
earlier that week?
Are you doing?
I don't know.
Oh,
what for Valentine's Day?
I don't know yet.
It hasn't been,
it hasn't been determined.
Okay.
And there's,
you know,
nothing came up.
No.
All right.
Maybe we're working on that shit man.
You know what I'm saying?
You feel me?
Don't talk about,
you know what I'm saying?
This is funny.
Um,
the uh,
you know,
the male or the,
the dad accent.
Yeah.
So a guy in a documentary,
they get to a mail order bride start speaking English with an accent.
Cool.
And so you can actually hear and then the narrator to makes it clear that he's
doing that.
They does a dad accident for her.
Here's the guy which doing FIFO.
Oh No,
no,
no.
So this guy,
welcome to America
doesn't speak with that accent,
right?
Yeah.
He's just a regular good welcome to America.
I don't think that a lot of us have experienced this with our own dads.
And um,
yeah.
If,
if you have an American dad and he tries to connect with somebody from another
place that a he'd sometimes it talks English the way they talk to maybe,
maybe you understand more when I say it the way I think you would say instead of
just speaking to them in English.
Um,
was it last week that we played the soccer player?
Yeah.
Or wake before,
was it the week before that?
Anyways,
we got some feedback on that.
Well also that he's not Irish,
but the cheat sheets that Irish,
you gotta blame blue band on that one.
Everybody was like,
he's not Irish mate fucker.
I think he's from Liverpool,
Liverpool.
But uh,
but,
but that was 100% blame,
blame blue band.
Um,
so here,
listen to the narrator talk about how this guy is doing this
to help Olga understand his English.
Gary speaks to her with a Russian accent.
I know you understand much.
You will,
you will ask me.
You will tell me.
I don't understand
if you do not say I don't understand,
I keep talking.
Do you think that helps her like I don't think so.
I'm trying to think of me speaking me to another language and I always think
I've responded better just hearing them speak however the languages to,
because it doesn't help you when they cause what they do.
When someone does that to you and you're trying to understand,
it complicates things in your brain because you're like,
wait,
what are you saying now?
And then you know that it's off.
Like you know that it's not correct.
Yeah.
So party.
He was like,
well,
I wish,
I wish I was hearing how to say it correctly because then you'd learn it
correctly.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
It's a total,
it is a dad.
Oh Wow.
That's so crazy.
Yeah.
They totally called him out too.
Well,
I mean,
they're like,
they have to talk like point out why he's being retarded.
These poor women.
Could you imagine that's your way out of this country out of Russia.
Oh,
is some fucking dip shit from,
we watched that one documentary,
God,
and it was like the saddest dude's.
Yeah.
And they would go to these meetups and then they're like,
I like,
you know,
she's like,
I like money.
I mean,
I like you two are the worst,
you know,
this is how bad it is.
Some of those women were in dire,
just like bad situations,
and the guy was so unfuckable and such a desperate,
sad that
the women would go like,
no,
I'll stay.
I'd rather I'd rather live in a shit.
Horrible country.
Yeah.
This froze.
I applaud shit box of the country and the Ukraine.
They go with you.
Yeah.
Some of them were in bad.
They showed them when he's like living in horrible,
you know,
tiny apartment with 10 people and they go,
this is my only chance out.
And then they would meet fucking Sam,
you know,
from such monsters.
They meet the,
uh,
the guy that invented McAfee.
Oh yeah.
You want a hundred bucks?
No,
her bucks.
You could take a shit.
Yeah,
I got ticket.
Boop.
Yeah.
Do it in the hammock.
Are you sure they all be done?
I'm going to be fixing some stuff underneath it.
I got to fix it.
Uh,
so that's like,
as the shit comes out,
he jerks off.
Oh,
is that what he's doing?
Well,
he says fecal sex and they go,
did you ever have intercourse?
And he goes,
they go,
no,
never scat sex.
Got Sex.
Shit's,
he goes off.
Wow.
What a Gig Gig.
Sure.
Those chicks are still like,
I've kind of where she was back here,
you know.
Well,
it's easy money.
It is a win win.
I got to shit.
I like to sit down when my shit,
you've got the hammock.
You've got the mouth.
Yeah.
Now he likes it fresh out of the oven.
That is just wild.
How does he not vomit?
Do you think he eats the shit or he just spits it out?
Yeah.
But even like here,
your nose is right there.
A fresh Turd.
Most of us have that reaction that,
that,
that not good reaction.
Um,
but I dunno,
he doesn't,
you know,
come on man.
He's fun.
He's not barfing
barfing he's just cleaning a shower.
Drain.
There's a smell sometimes.
Yeah.
So the problem,
the,
I think you're having right now
is that your personality is not allowing you to enjoy this moment.
Um,
I think the problem is your personality doesn't respect other people's
personalities.
And preferences.
Dude.
Shit in the mouth.
And how many girls did it?
I mean they got three on camera.
Who liked vomit too.
That's true.
Shit worse though.
I Dunno.
Wait a minute.
I don't know.
She had to know.
I think vomit for me worse.
So you have the option.
I'm going to shit on your lap or puke on your lap.
I would take the shit.
Really?
You know that I have such a
phobia.
Eye opening moment right now.
It's just no personalities got,
they're on grade level.
I have such a fear of vomiting.
I really don't like it.
I can't hear it.
I can't smell it as you can't do it all sometimes.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but shit,
I feel like every day I get shit on my hands changing diapers.
So it's like,
all right,
I'm knee deep in it.
It is horrible.
It is fucking,
yeah.
I mean hell,
Jay's puked on me.
I've smelled it.
It's not good.
So the Fucker,
what did they just say?
Ah,
yeah.
See How shitty your personality is and you would even know
do something.
A lot of people would be like,
that guy's got a fun personality.
He's having fun with that person.
Okay.
A lot of sociopath.
Like you know man,
a horrible are hilarious.
You want to spoil?
Yeah.
Let's see what you think.
So this is a,
I guess in the middle of a mouse taking place there.
Some shit.
My Mail
[inaudible].
Okay.
So what they did was they,
it's a Pr Japanese prank show.
So they'd set this guy up to go to a meeting and then they make it look like a
sniper across the whatever the way of crossing the building shoots the three
other people in the room.
The terrified the guy.
Right.
Well,
I didn't laugh.
Did you?
I seen this one.
Um,
oh,
you're smiling on the inside and I enjoyed it.
Yeah,
it's fun when you see them really scared.
Right.
That is the fun part,
right,
is when people are really scared.
Well,
but you know,
that was not imminent danger.
In other words,
it's not a real sniper.
Can I watch it again?
Knowing that now?
Yeah.
Can,
let's see if it reads and see if it's funny or to,
yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
Let's see if I know the premise now.
Yeah.
So here's the guy.
These are all actors and they have special effects and they're going to make it
seem like somebody shoots through the window.
Cool.
[inaudible] good.
It's kind of too short of a clip to see the real terror right now you can watch
these at length and see more,
you know.
See,
I have,
I have this pesky thing called empathy.
Yeah.
That doesn't allow me to like laugh when people are genuinely terrified.
I personally,
it's just a small problem.
Yeah.
Well,
but it's also kind of like one of those none fun parts of your person.
There's a lot of people.
Oh,
the empathy part please.
Excuse you mean?
Oh,
the,
the excuse.
So you lol.
I was on mute.
I wasn't really like hyperventilating,
laughing,
but I,
I certainly had a couple of chuckles,
but you have to watch that at length because you can really see them panic.
Thank you.
That's a neat,
thank you for playing this really fun.
Also what I like is last night I go to bed before you,
I always do.
And you,
you go,
I got to watch my shows and of course I got to watch my show,
watch my shows and I go murder.
And you go,
yeah,
I go,
what part?
Why would you want to watch murder,
killing sociopaths stuff right before bed you go,
it's going to affect your dreams for sure.
Is it going to affect your dreams?
It seeps into your unconscious mind.
Oh he's in a my mind cause I'm sleeping and I can hear all the stuff.
Like they found blood on Teresa's naked body or dismembered head found in the
court yard across the street in the apartment and like,
I don't want to hear this at all.
I mean it's a nice,
I think it's a nice way to kind of drift off into the Muslim there.
Yeah.
I mean look,
most of the shows are all about solving.
Okay.
So that's,
that's what you're watching.
But yeah,
but no,
cause you like the shows where they're like,
and there hasn't been a crack in the case in 20 years.
But then,
I mean,
the one I watched last night,
they,
uh,
I watched them solve it and he liked the ones where it's the women.
It's always some cute 20 year old girl lives alone and she's abducted or raped
or murdered.
Well,
I mean,
you can,
it's kind of fun to picture yourself trying to commit the crime and then trying
to get away with it.
And then,
you know,
then you picture being the detective and you're sure you go,
how would I solve this?
But then you go,
oh,
what?
I want the guy to get away with it.
Sure.
Yeah.
This is the fun part of your personality I was talking about,
but really it was a really good,
uh,
it was a good murder case where they solved it.
Then the dominate the dummy wrote his name,
uh,
on her chalkboard.
He did.
Yeah.
His real name,
his real name,
he wrote,
Dennis was here.
And when they asked him about her,
he was like,
no.
He was like,
I know she is,
but I've never been there.
And then they go,
because this is on our chalkboard.
And he was like,
Oh,
you know what I did.
That's right.
I was in there and then,
and then he was like,
just running,
you know,
talking in circles.
And then he was like,
you know,
I actually witnessed the murder.
Okay,
so the guy do it.
What a neat thing to have before bedtime.
Huh?
I still have like an angel.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I can't do it.
I can't watch that stuff before bed.
Why?
What happens?
Bad Dreams.
Negative dreams.
But you would just picture yourself solving a murder and then he got the title.
I like it.
I even have to ask you to turn it down about five times.
Well,
you asked me to turn everything down and you're getting worse with it used to be
fun and you used to go,
hey,
I like when you listen to the TV,
watch TV.
When I,
I'd be like,
great,
I'll watch a show now.
Every two minutes ago he turned it down a little bit and I go,
okay.
And then I turned it down.
It's like volumes,
single digit.
It's on set.
And he tied down Lamar.
I go,
okay.
I can barely hear you
homeless.
They still,
they still too loud.
I'm trying to say why do I sound like a Hobo?
That's how you sound.
You Go,
Eh,
trying to say it too loud.
All right.
Like keep turning it down.
It's because I can't sleep because you want it.
Your bell tones out when you go to bed
because you watched dumb shit.
My favorite thing you've been watching because it's football season or these
interviews they do when the team either wins or loses
perspective on football coverage has completely opened a humor portal that I
didn't know existed.
Like I didn't realize first you nailed it with the football songs.
Oh,
it's like
fuck you guys ready to play
and how does those pm Sunday night football songs are and now you pointed out to
me that,
what are the interviews like?
Well the interviews are stupid because if the team loses and what they do is
they carved out the poor son of a bitch who played his heart out and lost and
now he's completely destroyed.
He's teased.
He just wants to be alone and drink or do whatever.
And they're like,
what?
What happened out there?
And he's like,
well I didn't play as good as I thought I could.
And then we lost.
That's all they fucking say it over and over.
Well,
I mean I didn't do it as good as I could as well as I could have.
And then if they win,
well you guys won.
How did you win?
Well,
we practiced a lot.
And that's what made us win the game.
Well through,
there's all,
it's the same shit.
Yeah.
And then we practice a lot and then we won practice real good.
And then the winning happens.
Well how are you even worse?
We didn't practice so good.
And then
of course they won because they prepared better and they fucking won.
And the guy who lost the,
you know,
he feels like shit,
let him let him be alone.
Let him be alone.
Don't card them out.
But I don't know.
I get so fucking bored.
And the worst are when they try to make jokes,
they do the playbacks and then,
cause I don't understand the context.
All I hear a home,
that's how that guy does that.
And then they're like,
why are you
the sports center?
They need better writers.
They have have
a few genuinely funny guys.
Like if you,
if you look at the lineup of the commentators,
there's probably,
I would say five or six genuinely really funny guys.
Problem is,
it's like any other hang it.
They pepper them with not funny guys who then try to compete with the really
funny guy.
And that's,
that's the real problem because there's some real funny
dudes.
Yeah.
And then there'll be,
you know,
then they'll hire like just a straight up game analysts guy who was like,
oh my God.
And he'll start throwing in his like his dad jokes.
Not only that,
a lot of these guys are not kick.
That guy's on the panel
and it's always at his own shit.
Those guys are always at their own.
Horrible.
Yeah.
And then another thing that really chaps my ass is how unattractive 98% of those
dudes are on these fucking panel shows.
The women like these fucking basset hounds are on TV to crap.
It
hold that dog sleeping on that heaven pillow.
If beef loves people pillow,
it might be blue band here or something.
Right?
Blue Band.
Maybe you think he's here?
Maybe no.
To pick.
Yeah.
Maybe here to pick up these cards.
No,
you don't think so.
She just barks.
But she barks at the sky.
She barks in nothing.
No,
no,
no.
He would be at the window.
Um,
what was I talking about?
How ugly these fucking dudes are.
It's true.
God,
you also pointed that out to me.
Something I'd never considered it because I don't think about how good looking
at guys.
But then you started to be like,
they let this fucking guy on television started to look at them and be like,
Oh yeah,
that guy doesn't look like he should be.
No.
And if you look at the sports casters that are female,
the ones even down on the field,
they are fucking tendrils in their hair.
Perfect makeup.
It's blizzard outside.
And she's like,
how do you think that the thing went today?
And she looks amazing.
There's only like three or four dogs that are women that are really,
yes,
there's a couple real fucking hounds,
but,
but are they like actual athletes or former APP sometimes or they're just,
they're actually good.
No,
some of them are just actually good at the job.
You know,
like they're still good at that job that are actually good.
There's a few that need to get the boot,
but there's,
um,
but there's definitely like some,
some that you go,
she's just attractive.
The hot chick that has no business.
I just love,
I've always loved sports.
The gender trader.
Well,
I do say that because there is such a double standard.
I mean,
Jesus Christ and if fuck,
it's ridiculous.
Well thank God I don't watch football so I just have to hear it when I'm falling
asleep.
You want to explore for a moment the pup training again?
Oh my God.
I've been waiting for pub training.
Can I urinate first?
You want to urinate?
I had been drinking so much water.
I'm so hydrated.
He really quick.
So press pause.
Okay.
One moment.
Okay,
we're rolling.
How was it?
Did you break?
It was good.
I pushed hard and it all came out.
Yeah.
Um,
I've been waiting all week for these clips,
uh,
well to um,
kind of get people,
remind people of what would you forget if you listen to the last episode,
because I think some people might have been like,
well what was that?
And so in three 71 a month or two ago,
whatever that was,
we introduced you to pup play in a very accessible,
nonthreatening way,
you know,
and nonsexual,
it's just,
that's what
I feel.
I feel like I have to live two lives in some ways
it's just guys quit crop
the sexy times when Fox,
not the whole awesome
just being dog.
That's not the whole essence of it,
Tom.
Absolutely.
No,
it's just pups here today for training too,
to test their skills.
So show me a kneel position.
There you go.
See now why can't,
my question is what's wrong with three or four guys getting together in a room
with a cage wearing latex and dog masks?
There's certainly nothing wrong with that.
I think what's also good about nothing being wrong with it.
It's also,
it's just a hang,
you know,
there's,
and there's,
there's nothing misleading about this obviously well produced segment.
I mean it looks good.
It sounds
good.
We sent that.
He's Seiko that belongs to somebody in the room.
Well done.
He was just sniffing those boxers on the floor,
but that's,
I mean,
who doesn't sniff dirty boxers?
What's interesting is the guy here,
the trainer gets into the fact that he's also a pioneer.
Right.
There wasn't any other trainers.
There wasn't anyone to teach me.
No,
he's doing it.
I had to go at him,
learn and put together the ideas.
Wow.
What are some of the ideas?
An innovator.
I happen to have a clip of some of the training time during your work day or
during those moments when you're in class.
Okay.
You want to go here?
Would your hand down your pants,
grab your nuts,
have a feel?
Okay.
Could you fingers over them?
Right.
Bring them up.
Yeah.
It's so amazing.
You know,
it was fun.
It wasn't any other parts and stuff and philosophy.
Oh,
and also from kinesthetics and safe with psychology and putting that all
together.
I've become a trainer
and I own pups.
Who are you backing it again?
Notice that.
Here's your honor.
Our own dogs barked during.
This truly is a dog trainer.
He's like,
I'm a no.
What's your ducts smell like at different times of the day?
In the morning when you wake up,
have a phone,
have a phone door.
Oh my God.
If you're nuts now,
thanks.
Take a smell.
A woman in America hasn't seen that.
Every morning emails came in.
You know?
I think when we originally aired the clip,
some of them said it was British and we were like,
and then,
and then we got a bunch of emails saying,
this guy's not key.
We at all.
It does Australian.
Oh for fuck sake.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well Australian or Kiwi,
it's how bad it is.
What?
It doesn't matter.
As long as you,
you're fucking,
you've done that.
The back run your finger along the crack of your ass.
You don't need to finger your whole,
you don't want to come back with shit on your finger.
Oh,
thanks.
Just run your finger along.
You crack your sweaty crack.
Oh my God.
Bring it up and smell.
Yeah.
That's nice.
Be Nice to shake his hand right after.
Just a couple of dudes hanging out in lay tech thing.
Hops here today for training too.
To test their skills.
So pop.
Yeah,
show me a kneel position.
There you go.
Just hanging out just about being a double.
I'm going to be honest and I'm going to be awkward and about who I am.
Please don't that.
I'm not ashamed of the fetish.
I'm not ashamed of the people that are hard.
Well,
how's your shift?
And I suppose that my work people,
it's a normal community.
[inaudible]
it all should be hiding it away.
Should we get that off?
So boy,
to take a time out while you're at work,
go to a cubicle for the toilet at the phone.
Have a quick set when you get home.
Oh God.
As you take off your underwear,
have a very good Dave Smith Smith.
The different parts of your underwear different.
What's your ass smells like?
Oh,
I know.
What's your cock and bull smelling?
I think we all know.
Yeah,
but don't you feel like,
you know,
series of pop is,
it smells like human pop really connects with odor and sentence smell.
So he really is
Oh,
G train.
Are you thinking about that now?
I'm so proud of him.
Yeah.
Don't you feel like you already know what your cock and balls and your asshole
smells.
I've gotten uh,
a bit of a,
yeah.
Most guys do.
Yeah.
I don't feel like you need to play a few loads of calm.
Oh,
um,
to take time out of your day.
You know,
it was super fun doing this week since this clip came into our lives
is um,
is I beyond the bed and I'd be like,
Tom,
if he,
can you do something for me?
If you have a minute today and then he'd be like,
what if like you put your hands down your pants and just take a sniff or your
cock and balls.
It was fun.
Yeah.
Because you fell for it a few times,
which is super great.
I'm like,
Tommy,
can you do me a favor?
And you're like,
what?
Burn?
What's your raw smells like?
Yeah.
Yeah,
man.
That's so good.
Yeah.
How do you think how this is?
See even this one I can understand.
Yeah.
This one I get,
I love dogs.
I understand that.
Yeah.
I don't understand getting shit in your mouth.
I think that's gnarly.
Yeah,
that's,
that's pretty wild.
I don't want to smell another guy's ass.
Right?
Hm.
When you say you don't want to,
what do you mean though?
I don't know.
Yeah.
How much for you to do this?
Oh,
um,
I mean to my own,
I've definitely,
everyone's smelled their own.
Know how much for you to take training to go to New Zealand or Australia,
wherever this is.
Yeah.
Sign up for pop class.
I want you in full lay techs outfit.
This guy would abuse me though.
This guy is,
this guy is one of those guys just like,
just like some guys do it with chicks.
Did the,
it's their angle.
He's like,
I'm pump training you and then he fucking locks you in a cage and sticks it in
your butt.
You know how,
okay,
so you're either in pub training,
would you rather,
yeah.
You're doing full pub training,
right?
Run your finger along incorrect.
If you Ross,
you don't need to figure your home.
You don't want to come back with shit on your finger.
You don't need to finger your whole,
I like how he,
he just makes that distinction.
Yes.
Don't sneeze to different parts of your underwear.
Yeah.
Go ahead and sniff.
Sniff,
sniff it.
The different parts of your underwear.
So,
but do you have to sniff another guys is just get a quarterly happens.
Yeah,
we saw them training.
So you go to pub training or horrible or are you stay with all McAfee in police
training and you do how many training?
Well,
I'm shitting in his mouth.
You got it.
No problem.
You're shutting in McAfee's mouth.
Yeah.
Every morning you wake up,
you have your coffee and when you feel it,
Bruin,
I feel bad for McAfee.
Of course.
Yeah.
I mean there's,
there's,
it's not going to be nice.
Yours are terrible.
Terrible.
But the mean,
it's still,
it's shit.
But yeah,
without question,
this over pub training.
Oh,
now what if you're the one who's getting shit in your mouth?
There's no question.
There's definitely,
that's not happening.
What?
So you would rather do,
you would rather have those prostitutes should in your mouth and do pub pub
training.
I mean,
you're a McAfee or pub training baby.
It's just simple.
I just,
uh,
this is really upsetting right now.
You have to pick one.
It's the fucking rolls.
It's would you rather so you have to pick one.
MMM.
I guess I'll be up fucking pop.
I guess I'm puffing pop.
No
pop training.
Yeah.
To sniff your masters.
Good photo of your nuts.
God.
Width of your Masters Groin.
Don't put your finger in your ass.
You don't,
you don't have to put it in there.
Yeah,
I know.
I love her.
It's like if you have some time in your day,
just unlace your leather pants.
This is good to another cubicle.
I don't know if he knows his,
but cubicles are wide open.
Yeah.
Stick your hand in there and then and just during day.
You have a free moment because you have to get to know your scent.
Right.
Strengthen your son Ray,
build your mosque.
I think this guy's terrifying.
Terrifying.
Yeah.
Well because it's that mild mannered horse shit and I know this is just called
pup play.
It's a little thing
and then the next thing you know he's telling you not to finger your ass hole.
Just smelled the sweaty crag.
Stark
smells like coconut balls.
Smell like,
yeah,
we know.
Everybody knows what they're going through and knows that drill because everyone
is checked underwear.
Of course he goes,
oh yeah,
that's bad on you smell,
but you smell yourself all the time.
I don't.
I don't need to.
Now I am going to go the workout right now when I'm done I'm going to let you
sniff it.
Well,
you save the panties for pup training.
Now you have to ejaculate into one part of the panel.
Yeah,
loads,
loads the same pair just over and I'm sure guys do that all the time.
I'm sure of it,
but I'm sure it his or particularly gnarly.
Maybe that's how he gets people like Christmas gifts for him or just his used
underwear and he's like,
I got you something nice.
That's a nice part about having this fetish isn't it?
It's Kinda Nice.
Kinda easy that way.
Alright.
Farts effective.
Uh,
hold on.
Say thank you to Megan and Megan.
Oh my God.
Thank you Megan and Megan for the unbelievable Valentine's Day cards.
I think we should save them and like read them closer to Valentine's Day and
this is,
we should mention the third edition that Megan and they're impressive have given
us.
I really enjoyed them.
These two women,
they make these valentime's uh,
just it relative to the shell.
They're all different.
Beer mom shows themed and it's really funny,
man.
I'm so excited to go through them.
I haven't had a chance.
Do you want to hear the big words or just like,
oh,
just like the gays.
Okay.
I liked that clip a lot.
Just like the gays who made this leg the gate.
Would you ever want to date your mouth?
Uh,
DJ boy butter.
I said,
I really would thank you for listening to the show.
Don't forget your mom's house,
podcast.com uh,
deep bro.
I talk about Cameron Dallas this week.
I don't know if you've seen that kid on Netflix.
He's a social media star and I feel,
Oh,
I talk about discipline and your discipline for losing weight.
Yeah,
it was good.
And stuff like that.
Take emails.
This guy says he's a sociopath and he's a 30 year old virgin and he wants to
know how to get laid.
So that's on this week's episode of that steep pro.
Check it out.
God Damn.
Alright,
thanks guys.
We love you my jeans.
You're my son.
I'm your mom.
Pass.
And when you asked him,
when you get your mom,
you're son,
I'm your mom did just like the gate.
It just like,
just like the gate.
I looked at her and she looked at me
like the gate
once my wife calls me,
mom,
you,
I mean
both consenting adults.
Ask him when you asked him.
When I looked at her and she looked at me,
and you're my son,
I'm your mom.
Because like the gate,
just like,
just like the gate,
ask them,
will you pass pass,
pass if just like the gate.